[Music]
so
there's a truck driver who's about to
out oust
a new jersey senate uh state senate
president
after he only spent 153 dollars on his
campaign shut the [ __ ] up oh yeah i just
saw this this morning um how do you know
what to say he's in new jersey uh what
is he us a governor now or a uh state
senator oh state senator alstom yeah we
didn't beat him
[Laughter]
donuts for his campaign mostly
uh for like some of the people
volunteers we're working for yeah that's
all you have to do okay yes no well he i
just saw this like i think it was on cnn
or whatever but they're just like hey
you just beat the democrat there and
then he's all like
i didn't beat him
the state of new jersey
did good answer damn he's already good
he's a man of the people he knows how to
talk that's a truck driver yeah he's
just some dude just
like regular everyday dude and he beat
one of the the most uh longest serving
uh politicians in new jersey good it
probably means that guy was doing a
shitty ass job bro everyone's just like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i already like donuts
dude 153 in donuts is like a million
dollar suit that's a lot of fun maybe
that guy you don't know what it is
like five bucks i know dude they're
expensive now everything's so good
jersey's pretty interesting because um i
don't know where you guys go they have
jersey city
and then like out there it's it's pretty
blue and then right right yeah and but
the rest of it is pretty red
so he says that he he got into the raise
after he was denied a concealed carry
permit just despite having a clean
record so he's like why the [ __ ] i mean
jersey's as bad as california though
when it comes to it's actually worse
than california when it comes to like um
how strict their gun laws are damn
really jersey why
i don't know it's just you know
different states different laws you know
what's crazy is i thought the whole
state hated newsome and then he was
getting recalled right and then all of a
sudden he's back in that's crazy no i
think people hated him but they just
they didn't recall him no they didn't
vote him out it was
but when you go to sacramento the
capitol building all four sides have
[ __ ] newsome billboards so in his own
hometown imagine going to work every day
and you [ __ ] open the blinds and it
just says [ __ ] you everywhere you and
i'm like damn even you're like oh you
come in here
kind of
that's awesome
i should have signs
yeah because when they did the recall i
don't know what
the vote was single tier make sense i
don't think the vote was that close
though no yeah it was it was still a lot
of people keeping them in office because
nobody wanted larry elder in california
l.a county like they're the ones that
carried that
there's just la is the one that carried
the win
yeah that's very true actually the rest
of california like [ __ ] hates them
yeah easier to win that but td ballet
like oh my god news makes me comb
have you guys seen the other side of the
argument of as why they wanted to keep
them well they wanted to keep
the amount of money that would have been
wasted right it was just the yeah the
instability that you have to restructure
everything and then he can't really do
anything anyway like he's not the one
implementing all these [ __ ] laws
yeah dude i'm down to literally elect
anybody if i i'm not just pointing out
meet kevin the [ __ ] youtuber
i wanted him to do it i wanted him to do
it dude
was he he ran he ran meet kevin
no but it was like he was top ten though
he did the debates but in the top ten is
like three percent bro yeah yeah yeah
the only the closest one was the the the
black republican larry elder yeah elder
yeah yeah dude mr beast ran it we've
been over i know
because no democrat was gonna challenge
um you know
newsom no he's the standing guard was
going as what like an independent no no
as a democrat he was the only challenge
or him in another one but he was the
only challenger that was a democrat that
was running against mr beast would run
on the beast party
that's how i know he would win he really
called it the beast party
are those burgers good i don't know i've
never had one they look good i never
tried it could order one yeah do right
now you gotta do it at that pop-up or
something when it's when it's ready are
they still going on is that still
happening i think i saw i want to try it
he has burgers yeah yeah mr beast
burgers dude come on get with your [ __ ]
dude what does mr beast do like his
video content [ __ ] crosses the
internet with he gives away gives away
money really modern day [ __ ]
price is right kind of always thought
about that instead of trying to keep it
just give all your money away to get
more no [ __ ] no bro we're not missing i
do it for the fans also i'm not part of
this
you tell tiger belly to do that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] come over here tell us to
give money away
recently made a [ __ ] ton of money right
stop man and say the year you got to get
rid of your taxes right away so you
gotta like make me donate
the richest guy i know ridiculous didn't
that jack cost like six thousand dollars
oh this is from marshall we're hanging
by a threat dude
we can't give away anymore no one's
gonna have any more jobs left this guy
can't get new t-shirts
yeah t-shirts we're still the same
obviously mr beast do that though i
think i reflected your hat's so
expensive oh man
gave away five hundred thousand dollars
in one video wow but apparently he made
a million dollars apparently his tax
pack he just killed himself though
like good lord too many write-offs yeah
he dude he'll do a video where he's like
the last person to stop touching the
lamborghini he gets to keep it or
whatever i'm like [ __ ] hey this this
is just one video what's next week's
video
he just recently did that beach cleanup
thing that cost like 200 mil or
something he raised like 10 mil for 10
million did a fundraiser because i was
like 200 million
beaches those are my least favorite of
his videos i'm like
get back to the lambos and cool [ __ ]
he's doing some kind of squid game
things i'm like
yeah he's doing a squid game yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it was his most expensive video he's
gonna kill everybody
i don't know he would get away with it
yes i'm mr b we're in international
waters yeah i'm gonna kill 400 people
last man standing
all right you know this um news that i
saw today what was pretty crazy is that
it kind of um shocked a lot of people
because it's been pretty heavily
democrat
back to back to back right yeah so then
out of nowhere they're like blindsided
with the with this um republican trucker
like what the [ __ ] is going on and then
basically um this like
i saw another clip on cnn or whatever
this dude was was saying like us
democrats we gotta wake up and see how
out of touch we are to like outside of
the city like we're just kind of saying
our own thing and maybe alienating the
rest of america and i was like yeah that
might be kind of true because like a
republican stuff like that he's democrat
though you know but that's what i'm
saying like that is a republican talking
point now we got to be in touch with the
people and not except crazy that's so
crazy isn't it crazy how it flipped so
like now the republicans are more like
into comedy when they used to be a
[ __ ] like truck drivers used to be
democrats yeah you're right back to the
democrat let's watch this campaign
republicans were known to be more
uptight don't be saying that kind of
[ __ ] yeah they're like the christian
right super conservative crazy yeah
switch man it's switching like crazy
dude and did you see the new virginia
woman um senate or was she a senator i
forgot but she's like she's this black
lady just posing with guns and [ __ ] yeah
she's the lieutenant governor now she
just got elected
oh you can't hear the [ __ ] good job
dude but yeah
okay here we
go i'll give you donuts
i'm running for new jersey state senate
i've lived here all my life raising my
three kids i like this guy
i like his wife he said he raised my
three kids shows too
my opponent he died
is
[Laughter]
it's time for a change
yo no joke though when i'm driving
around jersey everybody got a [ __ ]
motorcycle in a truck
vote for me and we're there
edward
this guy's cool man where are people
voted for him because he's chill [ __ ]
calm yeah chinese walking places he's
going down for some uh racist tweets or
some [ __ ] dude
are you serious
i had to bring you guys he was my god
you guys talking about how sick this guy
is
i was like i support everything he said
in the past
[Laughter]
i saw this dude this morning and i was
like oh
finally we got a everyday [ __ ]
american just like representing what
race was he a racist against so here's
you guys want to guess asians asians you
[ __ ] corona virus [ __ ] everybody
actually oh really everybody gets dude
he's not racist anymore yeah so let me
let me let me let me read some of the
things that you got bigger dicks than us
right apparently he said
um get these ching chongs out of my name
there was a response to chelsea manning
tweet right if you know who chelsea
manning is
formerly bradley manning who was a
whistleblower gave a lot of information
about how the government spies on us
using the nsa
um
so
he responded to a screenshot of a
chelsea main tweet
by calling him she slashed him and shim
oh like shin lim oh i love shin like
holy [ __ ] live that's so asian he's
phobic right there right that's 100
transphobic all right unless he's just
ignorant he's from new jersey
this guy looks like he doesn't know
anything about pronouns in general
exactly he doesn't know what his own
pronoun
like just watching he's wearing shoes
from like the 1990s you would ask this
guy what's a pronoun he's like the [ __ ]
do i know
he could barely he could barely [ __ ]
spell truck driver he's like a person
place her thing what's that bro i don't
know
you